what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
and one of the most exciting upcoming
things about the MCU is the X-Men the
mutants we've been waiting for them for
years now since Marvel Studios got the
rights back from Fox to have the X-Men
and mutants in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now it's been a while now it's
been a while since Marvel Studios got
those rights and all the way back in
2019 at San Diego Comic-Con Marvel's
Hall age panel at the end of it Kevin
feige told us well they didn't even have
time to talk about the mutants or the
Fantastic Four then they didn't have
time to talk about the Fantastic Four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about
mutants and how are you
foreign
body thought well they must be coming
soon then however the next San Diego
Comic-Con that we got after the pandemic
which was in 2022 last year we didn't
get anything about the X-Men now we got
a little bit about the Fantastic Four
but nothing about the X-Men at all
however that is about to change as the
X-Men are about to come into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe not as most people
expect but if you've been following the
news you kind of know how however it
looks like there are more bigger and
grander plans for the X-Men to enter the
MCU relatively soon and we might
actually be getting a glimpse of some
new X-Men characters not old X-Men
characters but new ones coming into the
MCU in Phase seven but in the meantime
in the Multiverse Saga we're actually
going to see a pretty big X-Men Story
come to life and actually get finished
and I think a lot of fans are truly
going to enjoy what Marvel Studios has
planned for an X-Men story in the MCU
moving into the new saga of new mutants
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so if
you love The X-Men and Marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos and news also we're
doing a giveaway we'll talk about that
more at the end of the video so first
things first what you need to know if
you have not heard this yet the old
X-Men are returning we're talking about
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine most people
have heard about this because Hugh
Jackman himself with Ryan Reynolds
announced that he is coming back as
Wolverine so we're extremely excited
about that however he's not the only
original X-Men character returning it
looks like a good majority of the cast
of the original X-Men team is actually
going to be returning in Deadpool 3 and
other projects now we've heard one story
of what could possibly be happening for
Deadpool 3 but keep in mind this is just
one story of a complete movie and not
even just a complete movie but multiple
projects leading up to Avenger Secret
Wars on the end of a saga basically what
I'm saying is the story that Deadpool
and Wolverine are going to go to a world
where the X-Men rule that world and
Magneto rules that world that is just
kind of one stop along the Multiverse
and the journey of Deadpool and
Wolverine because remember eventually
Deadpool has to make his way to the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe Universe the
one with our Spider-Man are Captain
America our Hulk our Hawkeye our Scarlet
Witch Etc and he might be taking some
other X-Men with him recently The
Insider can we get some toast who has a
great track record has stated that we
are going to get a lot of character
Justice in Deadpool 3 and they posted a
picture of the original X-Men cast
Wolverine storm Rogue Cyclops Etc and
this lines up with what Kevin feige's
apparent plan was for the original X-Men
to make their way to the MCU since they
were not a part of it before remember
those exist in Another Universe the fox
universe but give them a chance to be in
the MCU and give them a chance to kind
of have another story eventually things
with the X-Men got kind of Muddy they
introduced the new X-Men characters and
then had them cross over in in one movie
with the old X-Men characters but not
all of the old X-Men characters were
there then when the Marvel Cinematic
Universe started you had some of those
original X-Men actors talk about how
they wish they could be a part of the
MCU they wish they had that back when
they were playing the X-Men characters
well that's Kevin feige's plan to get
them to be a part of it finally and for
those of you who may not be aware Kevin
feige is the president of Marvel Studios
currently and he started his career with
the first X-Men film so this is
extremely important to him so Deadpool 3
is an extremely important film because
we are going to see some of the old
X-Men cast return reprising their roles
as characters of the X-Men but here's
the biggest part it's not going to stop
there and we probably are going to get
different iterations of them in Deadpool
3. it's supposed to be a Multiverse film
which probably means Deadpool is going
to stop by more than one universe and
this report says that we're going to get
a lot of character Justice which
essentially means these characters are
going to kind of get their happy ending
which would mean Kevin feige they get to
come into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
now we know that between Avengers the
Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars we
might get some projects that take place
in other universes that's what secret
Wars is about other universes colliding
and kind of jumping into one universe
and then those Heroes the remaining
Heroes who are left have to figure out a
way to fix the Multiverse to save
everything well it looks like with the
original X-Men we're going to get two
different things one they are going to
be one of those teams in one of those
universes who end up colliding into
another universe and they end up on our
main universe or they simply leave their
main Universe because it is at risk of
incursion so they leave with Deadpool
and that could very well happen when
Deadpool visits a universe where
reportedly According to some rumors he
has to for the TVA kill this universe
that is filled with X-Men characters who
rule over it who Reign Over It with
Magneto in charge so there is a
possibility that Deadpool could kind of
get all of the good X-Men together in
that universe who don't truly want to be
on Magneto's side but would rather
overthrow him or overrule him he could
get together with those X-Men and they
could end up fighting Magneto's
Brotherhood and this could be the
justice that they are talking about
because this could be a pretty big fight
between good and evil mutants one in
which nothing else is involved no serum
that cures your mutation no humans
involved just the good Mutants versus
the bad mutants and after this if the
rumors are true if the TVA assigns
Deadpool to kind of take care of this
universe and get rid of it because they
can't well that means the universe has
to be destroyed they want to prune that
timeline so Deadpool being who he is
Deadpool someone who definitely does not
play by the rules perhaps he takes his
new friends with him in his little
multiversal journey and perhaps they end
up in our main universe and that's where
stuff really starts to go down bringing
other care characters from other
universes into our universe we already
know that that puts the universe at risk
of an incursion in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness Reed Richards
explained to us that when characters
from other universes go into universes
that are not theirs it destabilizes that
current universe and confuses it and
puts it at risk for incursion well
that's the whole entire point of Secret
Wars incursions and Multiverse jumping
so the X-Men could really have two
different pretty important stories to
play here one in Deadpool 3 and 2 for
Secret Wars but also if they do any
other projects that involve other
universes they could also play a pretty
big role in that story as well there is
definitely going to be some sort of a
superhero Council where a lot of
different heroes from other universes
get together and they talk about hey
what is the best way to defeat Kang what
is the best way to save our Multiverse
and I'm sure this X-Men team is going to
be a part of that so Deadpool 3 in some
way shape or form whether it is from
that Universe where the X-Men rule under
Magneto and then Deadpool ends up taking
taking them to the main universe or they
get taken from Another Universe that
Deadpool comes across the justice for
their characters is most likely going to
be them being included in the MCU and
not just them being in the universe but
actually having a part in the story that
is taking place and I for one would love
Professor Xavier and his X-Men to have a
part in trying to save the entire
universe I mean we already got Professor
X and Multiverse of Madness so clearly
Doctor Strange would know who he was
plus not to mention Professor X in
Multiverse of Madness was really kind of
the only one who trusted Doctor Strange
so Doctor Strange would probably trust
Professor X so when there is some sort
of a grand counsel I am expecting
Patrick Stewart's Professor Xavier to be
a part of that and to have the past
Marvel universes connect with the
current Marvel Universe and kind of play
a big part in concluding the Multiverse
Saga that would be just amazing Not only
would it be nostalgic and mean a lot to
the fans and mean a lot to Kevin feige
and the actors as well but it actually
makes sense to have them in the story
continuity wise it is actually fantastic
and I can't wait to really see the
characters get what they're calling
justice but let us know your thoughts
about that in the comments down below do
you like this idea do you like what
they're doing or do you not and if not
why let us know down below also don't
forget to subscribe and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month we also have a patreon
account a website and a Discord server
if you want to support the channel you
can check those out and of course don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf wolf
oh